what's uh the worst job you've ever had
working at Perkins oh I love Perkins
working there's not the best though
Perkins is like a white trash Denny no
offense to my Perkins fans out there
all we talk is money honey all we talk
is money we're here at Tortuga Country
Music Festival in Fort Lauderdale
Florida we're here for one reason we're
here to find out if country women make
good wives let's find out there's a song
that's called Take This Job and Shove It
what's uh the worst job you've ever had
Hooters it's not the girls it's the
managers love the customers the
manager's a little creepy or what yes
working at the movie theater I was in
box office selling the movie tickets my
acute dialysis nursing job by far it was
awful working at Buffalo Wild Wings not
gonna lie I was also gonna say Hooters
double Hooters out here they got the
Hooters what was the problem with
Hooters for you management
so bad they don't they don't take so not
the customers
harassment for the money if that makes
sense but not getting talked
that like managers don't pay me so you
can't talk to me like that and not pay
me ah so you'll deal with the sexual
harassment yeah
gotcha all right I mean I wouldn't but
that's just
working at Perkins oh I love Perkins
working there's not the best though
Perkins is like a white trash Danny no
offense to my Perkins fans out there um
Disney
Disney's gone too woke I guess
what do you think the hardest job is for
a man president
you support our president
no okay well you should vote for Trump
you mean like in like the truth like to
not cheat to not cheat that is the
hardest job great answer and honestly
being a marine being a real man being
out there fighting other men being in
service I think that's a difficult job
I'm sorry but if you haven't done at
least that I don't feel bad for you
respect I think just being a breadwinner
like you know that's a lot of pressures
you know what Breadwinner like you know
they have just being a man itself
respect
that's probably not fun in like area
Miner
Jesus stay faithful wow why do you think
men can't stay faithful too many options
and they're like little toddlers they
can't like it's kind of like a blonde
and a brunette and but also another
blonde a lot of options out here
okay yeah probably construction good
Construction
probably like construction work
something in the Labor Field there's a
song called working nine two five Dolly
Parton you know this one okay uh would
you rather work full time
have a full-time job or be a full-time
housewife
are you kidding
swipe
are you joking
South Park and Family Guy all day yes
okay you don't want to work you just
want to be a housewife so absolutely
tell me what ass off right now so do you
have a man
no okay
answer that real quick hands down tell
me what I hate working I work three jobs
so you want to find a dude to wife you
up just boom pop out some kids exactly
housewife for sure
one housewife that was dumb yeah so
that's an easy question yes why would
you rather be a housewife so you don't
gotta go to work
the glamor and the money that just comes
for free basically
all right boys buy or beware we'll be
gonna get these Housewives out here
I'd go nine to five nine I like being a
contributing member of society there it
is she's paying her taxes y'all work
full time
probably housewife she wants to get
wiped up work full time
yeah see I work full-time now so it's
not bad well would you rather
work full-time okay work full-time not a
question I would blow my brains out if I
was like [__] house
um I would do nine to five like yeah
we're working girls yeah working girls
in a working world let's see I'd rather
work a full-time job because if I was
sitting at home
being a housewife cleaning cooking the
dinner that's honestly not enough for me
I need to be behind the scenes a little
bit I have to be making people feel good
I own my own business I do hair and I
love making people feel good so that
wouldn't be enough for me you guys are
paying your way no man can tell you what
to do housewife you got a leash on you
yeah but don't you kind of want a man
telling you what to do on my terms on my
terms but if he's taking care of you
paying the bills you don't have to work
you got a good lifestyle isn't it kind
of on his terms yes it is so you just
kind of gave me a run around answer but
if I'm contributing to the household
then I still have a say what if you're
not contributing you're you're the
housewife you're the trophy wife you're
gonna be a housewife exactly there it is
these girls they don't want they're not
playing games out here
all right uh there's a song called Stand
By Your Man do you know this one Tammy
Wynette if your man fell on hard times
what would you do to build him back up
oh boosts the confidence telling me
looks hot he's successful he's gonna
make us rich am we gonna live in Fort
Lauderdale only man in my life is my dog
so I bring him to the vet
take care of that dog what was that
little r on the rich
okay all right so are you currently
doing that for your man or you don't
have a man I don't have a have him so
but I would do it for mommy hand
Talon is a star we know this but
hypothetically if you're a man
what did he do to fall down is he in
jail fell on a hard time
better I'll take care of him but did he
fall down a hard time or the hard times
that he like
he stole money or it's just like I don't
know economy your imagination is beyond
wild young little Bitties they don't
know
um I think just be supportive and just I
think men have a hard time with like
women take failure a little bit
different I think men just shut down so
definitely like being able to talk about
your feelings and like get therapy get
help men don't ever want to go to
therapy talk it out it depends on him
but pretty much everything that he needs
to get himself back on his feet like
what
bringing him his favorite food making
sure that he's got everything he needs
to start the day making sure he comes
home to a cooked meal clean house take
care take care take care of your man if
I'm with my man I support my man like I
will pick him up financially yeah
financially physically emotionally it
doesn't matter what it is if he needs me
I have his back respect emotional
support's important because if he's
doing the things he needs to do to try
and take care of himself I'll be there
to support him what would you say what
kind of words
just words of encouragement like just
remind him that it's gonna keep getting
better if you wanted to on Twitter and
keep working towards it I would just
hype him up I think men also need words
of affirmation go ahead hype me up right
now I'm having a bad day fantastic hair
is fresh you're so positive yeah your
your pecs are just like um they are
pecking they're just confidence
confidence confidence build me up you
know I was feeling kind of low before I
met you girls now I'm feeling like
million bucks feeling fresh just support
him I mean you know motivate him and
help him get better
um probably be his rock you wouldn't
leave him
no suck it up buttercup
s you would say to him yeah get on the
horse camp
I mean words of affirmation uh he knows
the five love languages watch out maybe
see
the song girl found your number in the
pocket of my blue jeans
picked up the phone let it ring
set him count down the miles back to you
babe
yeah I'm heading west on a big old jet
plane back to that California
Sunrise well done clap it up at home for
these ladies
[Music]